so let's get caught up yesterday I told
you based on the New York Times story
that was effectively corroborated by
Donald Trump jr. including through the
release of his emails this morning he
and Jared Kushner and Paul Manafort met
with a Russian lawyer in June of 2016 at
Trump Tower under the pretext of
receiving damaging information about
Hillary Clinton for the 2016 campaign
Donald Trump's juniors Donald Trump jr.
story changed drastically in 48 hours
okay
let's put up the various positions of
Donald Trump jr. on this issue from
March of 2017 up until three days ago
Donald Trump's jr. Donald Trump juniors
position was I've had no meetings with
anyone I've had no meetings representing
my father's campaign with any Russians
period by July 8th of 2017 well now he
admitted fine I did actually have a
meeting with a Russian but the meeting
was about so-called Russian adoption
which by the way actually relates to
sanctions as well and 24 hours later by
July 9th of 2017 he admitted yes the
meeting was ostensibly about getting
damaging dirt on Hillary Clinton to help
my dad but we didn't end up actually
getting that information uh this is sort
of an irrelevant distraction this issue
of whether they did or didn't get the
information Trump jr. and Kushner and
mana Ford intended to meet with a
Russian actor during the campaign at
Trump Tower for the purposes of
coordinating against Hillary Clinton now
that we've learned more about the full
explanation from Donald Trump jr. it
appears that not only did he lie but
that his admission about this issue
contradicts prior denials by endless
associates of the Donald Trump
administration January 2017 then
president-elect Trump says there has
been no contact between Trump associates
and Russia during the campaign wrong
November 11th of 2016 Trump spokeswoman
hope Hicks says there has been no
communication with foreign entities
wrong
of 2017 on Fox News Sunday Vice
President Mike Pence says of course not
when asked if there was communication
with foreign agents including Russians
July of 2016 Trump jr. himself says that
any suggestions that Russians tried to
help Trump are quote lies that is a
month after he was in an email chain
where it was mentioned seemingly not
even controversially that Russia was
worth working to help Donald Trump it is
lie after lie after lie and I always
found those denials to be a little bit
suspicious because they were so
declarative I mean when you're talking
about an entire campaign how could you
know for sure that maybe some low-level
staffer doesn't have any connections to
Russian somewhere but I think they were
trying to do it to try to get rid of the
issue altogether so it would go away but
as we've learned it's not going away do
you think they genuinely thought that
just issuing these blanket denials would
sort of end it and that nothing was ever
going to come of it or do a it's a
terrible strategy isn't it if they
weren't worried you'd think they
wouldn't have lied so many times about
the various contacts and there's two
major indicators right now that this is
becoming undeniable even for the Trump
administration number one and I
mentioned this yesterday over the last
two week weeks there's been a shift in
right-wing media from there was no
collusion to if there was collusion it's
not illegal that represents a major 180
in terms of the approach from right-wing
media that wants to defend Trump on this
the second indicator that the Trump
position on this is shifting is that
immediately after this broke Donald
Trump didn't go to Twitter to say it's
fake news Donald Trump didn't go to
Twitter to say that it's a witch-hunt
Donald Trump went to Twitter or maybe it
was through a spokesperson now I'm
forgetting and put out a statement
saying I didn't know about the meeting
and I wasn't at the meeting this is a
180 for Trump from his general process
which is basically say it's fake news
call it a witch-hunt and say the New
York Times is failing the entire
campaign or the entire administration
now is in complete disarray when
responding to this because you have some
people staying silent you have some
people admitting to the allegations as
Donald Trump jr. is
then you have some people still denying
the idea that there could have been any
possible collusion as Kellyanne conway
did when she went on CNN's new day
yesterday that was a disaster right
disaster I'm surprised that they let her
back on TV after the bowling-green
Massacre fiasco but she's back on I mean
maybe now she'll get pulled off again
what are the real questions now but the
real question for me now is when Trump
intends denied contacts with Russia
endless times were they telling the
truth or were they deliberately kept out
of the loop that's really the only
question that remains for me at this
time we will be following it I'm on
Twitter at the Pakman and the show is on
Twitter a David Pakman show I'm thrilled
that today's program is supported by
taga Deb the hosting specialists
offering whatever type of hosting
package is good for your business or
project this includes dedicated and
virtual private server solutions cloud
server options which are increasingly
popular as well as custom server
solutions taga dabs web hosting services
support a really broad range of
customers and businesses around the
world and this includes bloggers tech
startups traders and finance gamers web
developers really whatever you can think
of and you can scale their cloud servers
up or down to meet the particular needs
of your business and to also cut costs
by only paying for what you use you can
save 20 British pounds a little over 20
US dollars on cloud server options by
going to signup tag adapt calm /td PS
and using the coupon code TDPS 20 that's
sign up ta ga da be calm /td PS the
discount code all one word all lowercase
TD PS 20 check it out